un santé avec la lutte contre les
infections nosocomiales ces maladies
qu'on contracte à l'hôpital et qui font
quatre mille morts par an eh bien les
autorités viennent de publier le premier
classement officiel des hôpitaux et des
cliniques sur ce sujet classement qui
révèle que 6 % des établissements ou
encore de gros efforts à faire
nicolas lemarignier christian leroux se
laver les mains encore et encore plus
qu'une obligation c'est devenu un
réflexe au service réanimation de
l'hôpital saint joseph est ici une
solution miracle à remplacer le savon
solution hydro alcoolique ne nécessite
pas d'équipement particulier on l'a tout
le temps ou dans sa poche ou à portée de
la main
le l'acte en lui-même va durer trente
secondes et c'est beaucoup plus facile à
faire que le lavage des mains qui va
durer au moins une minute trente
grâce à des mesures comme celle ci
l'hôpital a diminué de moitié la
présence de bactéries dangereuses
en cinq ans le centre de soins figure en
catégorie p dans le palmarès des
établissements de santé en matière de
lutte contre les infections en haut du
classement la catégorie à 11 % des
établissements tout en bas la catégorie
celle des 5,9 pour cent de retardataires
la liste est disponible pour la première
fois sur internet région par région
ville par ville
on y découvre par exemple en bas du
palmarès la clinique de l'essonne
catégorie 144 lits principale activité
l'orthopédie pour son directeur les
critères d'évaluation sont déconnectés
des réalités du terrain ce tome est basé
surtout sur du formalisme c'est à dire
sur la boule n'ont les moyens mis en
place le nombre de réunions fait dans
l'année
le nom de d'études qu'on a pu mettre en
route dans l'année et non pas du tout
sur les résultats cette critique souvent
répété le ministre de la santé l'a
anticipé à peine rendu public le
classement va déjà évolué et d'un site
nous aurons notamment en octobre les
résultats du taux d'infection
nosocomiale établissement par
établissement aujourd'hui ce sont les
moyens engagés
nous aurons les résultats en
au mois d'octobre le gouvernement espère
sensibiliser fortement les
établissements de soins chaque année
4000 personnes meurent d'une infection
contractée à l'hôpital
les